I'm gonna miss you
I am going to miss you too and we could
just stay up here
I do that
hey I hear you up there
I love that you love it I'm just so
content taking care of other people's
pets
come with me
[Music]
laughs
come with me
winner
to my parents house for Christmas you
should know that it is very difficult to
sit next to you at dinner
no more surprises
I promise Riley this is Abby Abby is my
orphan roommate we I am an orphan but we
live together as friends like
acquaintances yeah nice to meet you
so I'm just gonna keep going by you guys
Abby
Abby honey are you okay oh I'm I'm okay
um
nothing against the door
um I'm just moving it right now sorry
it's heavy
morning why did you pluck the door
I I didn't want to sleepwalk again
well sorry to barge in the twins usually
stay down here I'm just getting them
Jane's old Game Boy good morning kids
morning Abby uh honey I'm heading to the
office but I wanted to let you know I
have invited Harry Levin and her husband
to our Christmas Eve party
what you heard what she said it's not
just about me it's about our whole
family and what is a better
representation of our family than your
Christmas Eve party
it is legendary
good day you know I will can't even
believe that that is two more people on
the guest list I basically have to
reimagine the entire party
found it
come on you two
look at it
I just want to go home I know I just
please let me say this
you are my family
I mean you are
the love of my life
I was terrible and and I wish that I
could undo everything but I promise you
I will make it up to you I will spend
the rest of my life making it up to you
and I won't hurt you like this again
please
give me another chance
I I want to build a life with you
please
what about your parents I no no I
I don't care what they think
I only care about you
if I have you that's all I need
be with me
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
what are you doing way over there get in
here come on
okay everyone say Christmas no don't say
that
[Music]